[Musique]
bonjour les enfants
la classe débute par la lecture de cette
lettre de jean jaurès aux enseignants
vendredi soir les enseignants reçoivent
une vidéo de leurs ministres leur
expliquant que bon c'est fini plus en
fait de temps de préparation et donc
vous avez des enseignants qui vont
arriver ce matin sans avoir été prêt
quoi que ce soit avec leurs collègues en
avoir confronté aux autres ce qu'ils
allaient pouvoir dire aux enfants ce que
j'exige du gouvernement c'est qu'il nous
fasse un retour une information sur
comment se sera déroulé établissements
scolaires par établissement scolaire
cette minute de silence
et s'il y a eu des provocations et bien
il faudra convoquer les parents
convoqués les élèves et qu'il y ait des
sanctions
comme je vous le disais au delà de la
question de la sanction il n'est pas
envisageable que cette minute de silence
ou que ces hommages soit perturbé et il
y aura évidemment des réponses ça devait
être le cas flanc plein coeur de l'école
nationale de police de nîmes
mercredi dernier alors que le couvre-feu
est de rigueur dès 21h une centaine
d'élèves policiers se réunit près du
stade de l'école dans une ambiance très
festive
j'attends le rapport du directeur
général de la police stationné cet après
midi pour me dire quels sont les élèves
concernés ces élèves seront exclues
parce qu'on peut plus ne seront pas
policier manon peut pas être policier et
se moquer des règles qu'on impose aux
autres pour être respectée faute
respectable attiré par le bruit
une patrouille de brigade canine loger
dans l'école se dirige vers
l'attroupement
elle est accueilli par des insultes et
décrit les mêmes que ceux utilisés en
général par les dealers
al'approche de la police je suis là pour
soutenir cette idée appelé bien sûr à ce
que les librairies réouvre le plus vite
possible d'image assez surréaliste 1
publié par des internautes des étagères
de livres bâché l'entrée des rayons
bloqué par des pancartes expliquant que
la vente de livres est interdite par le
gouvernement
plus ubuesque encore dans certains
hypers des rayons à moitié fermé
possibilité d'acheter les journaux et
les magazines mais pas les livres juste
à côté donc pour lui il ya deux mondes
ya justement pas il ya une égale celui
du salarié we call droite se met à le
droit de se mélanger et en revanche
celui du petit commerçant lui on le
ferme jamais d'affirmer que tout
simplement un autre s'insurge ainsi je
résume j'ai le droit d'acheter une télé
mais pas un livre dans le rayon d'à côté
le virus doit être plus présent dans le
rayon livres ironise un internaute quand
beaucoup évidemment souligne qu amazon
n'en demandait pas tant que des rendez
vous le 12 novembre nous puissions
rouvrir un certain nombre de commerces
avec des règles sanitaires avec par
exemple la possibilité de prendre
rendez-vous dans les commerces les
rapports des manuels macron avec les
intellectuels est extrêmement ténus il
préfère faire rentrer en général à
l'elysée avant d'inviter des comics des
pétomane des rigolos et des imitateurs
plutôt que des écrivains et ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on ait pas douter les
attaques mais restant sur les librairies
nous allons diviser les tarifs postaux
d'envoi des livres au moins par 3 3 ou 4
donc on va diminuer considérablement les
frais de poste des libraires c'est très
attendu c'est très demandé le livre est
un bien essentiel parce qu'il fait
partie des oeuvres de l'esprit cloisons
nous sommes un pays qui défend 16h06
aliette et d'expression la culture et
donc comment se fait-il qu'on considère
que c'est bien là ne soit pas moi je
m'apprête d2b civiquement au confinement
je vais arrêter
je vais arrêter nous confiner je vais
arrêter de remplir les fiches niveau
pour sortir je tairai toutes les amendes
je suis même d'accord pour payer les
amendes des libraires qui voudraient
ouvrir leur librairie
après le confie l'enjeu des élections
moi je veux des élections on a on a
passé le confinement je suis d'accord on
fait des élections d'hier est ce que
vous allez bien géré ça ou pas non non
dors là aussi sa présidence m